welcome to the show the Obama
administration opposed the regime of
Bashar al-assad a brutal dictator war
criminal who has killed thousands of his
own people in Syria and on Thursday at a
press conference in Ankara Turkey
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
suggested that the current
administration the Trump administration
has no qualms with Bashar al-assad
staying in power Rex Tillerson said
quote the longer term status of
President Assad will be decided by the
Syrian people the same day in New York
City nikki Haley our new fearless
ambassador to the United Nations
reaffirmed the White House's stance she
said quote our priority is no longer to
sit and focus on getting Assad out so in
terms of policy the Trump administration
is seemingly a effectively giving Assad
a free pass on his crimes against
humanity this probably makes Russia very
happy who have been fighting in the
Syrian civil war alongside Assad sort of
under the pretext of being against Isis
and against extremist groups to be super
clear going to war with boots on the
ground in Syria is not the same as
opposing Assad and wanting him out of
power so all of the people that now are
speaking up and saying why is this the
view of the Trump administration it is
not that they're suggesting of boots on
the ground full-scale operation against
Syria but it is a questioning of the
Trump position especially in light of
the suspected collusion between Trump
and Russia and how Russia plays into
this five days later just yesterday the
day before in the province of Idlib the
Assad regime executed one of the worst
chemical bombings against rebel occupied
territory the war has ever seen a war
crime by a number of international
treaties at least 58 civilians were
killed including at least 11 children
under the age of eight many of you have
seen the videos floating around they're
absolutely brutal some reports are much
higher hundreds of others injured many
critical so the death toll is bound to
increase and later in a nearby town a
hospital treating victims was also
bombed killed killing 15 people
there are no military installations or
personnel anywhere near the sites of the
attacks just civilians in residential
areas period and there's a local doctor
fierce jundi who said quote the people
in it liver terrified everyone here is
waiting for death this is understandably
created outraged worldwide but the
Syrian government has already gotten
away with so much during this war with
very little in the way of repercussions
and this sort of wink wink nod nod from
the Trump administration I assumed Pat
is only going to further embolden the
Assad regime to continue committing
atrocities there's really no easy way
out of this because if you do commit to
ground troops that's going to cause a
lot more civilian deaths yes and likely
further destabilize the Middle East but
if you do nothing you let Assad to
continue and you let Russia have
influence on that region the bombs
dropped by helicopters are believed to
have contained sarin gas which the
Syrian government actually vowed to stop
using back in 2013 in an agreement with
the US and Russia sarin is an odorless
colorless nerve agent that can kill you
within a minute after inhalation or just
one drop of the liquid on the skin can
also kill you international
investigators are going to start
examining rockets to find out for sure
what they use but based on the videos
that have been seeing that is what is
believed to have been used there the
number of deaths is way too high for it
to have been chlorine and the symptoms
seem consistent with sarin now yesterday
Sean Spicer the Donald Trump press
secretary commented on this and blamed I
hope you're sitting down President
Barack Obama quote from Sean Spicer
these heinous actions by the Bashar
al-assad regime are a consequence of the
past administrations weakness and a
resolution this is after the Trump White
House said that Bashar al-assad was not
one of their priorities not that we
should necessarily put boots on the
ground to fight Assad that's not what
I'm saying but this is pure unmitigated
hypocrisy by the White House and let's
take it a step further again Russia
recall
that Russia is aligned with Bashar
al-assad under the pretext of fighting
Isis and defeating extremists but as a
result is more and more complicit in the
atrocities of the Assad regime and now
you have the Trump administration
increasingly aligned with that this is
bad all around Pat and once again what
side is Trump on here and it's one thing
to blame the situation that you're in on
your predecessor it's another thing to
not have a plan and a course of action
to make up the ground that was
potentially lost by your predecessor no
doubt about it and you know immediately
did whenever we cover a story like this
by the way based on the YouTube d
monetization crisis you can bet that
there is no chance in hell that this
video on YouTube is going to have any
ads running on it but it's a serious
issue and my planet to continue talking
about these issues immediately when you
start talking about this people who just
want to slam what you're saying we'll
find some overlap in what you say with
some other entity and they'll say you're
parroting the X narrative so depending
on your position on this I've already
seen it online are our friends and
co-host show host of other shows
whatever their opinion is they are
either complicit with the official
narrative or their conspiracy theorists
or their Isis sympathizers isn't it
possible that you have an opinion that
you've formed based on researching the
story from a number of angles and there
might be overlaps with other people that
doesn't mean you're in the tank for any
particular element especially on this
issue in particular because the Syrian
government using these chemical weapons
is that war with Isis and there's so
many other powers that play here
including the United States and Russia
so it's very nuanced it's very tough to
come up with something that can satisfy
everyone there's also the aspect of what
should the u.s. involvement be with a
Syrian free army which John McCain has
talked about and overlaps with the
opinion of some Democrats and and and
doesn't with others if your response to
this is going to be you're in the tank
with X narrative it's not useful it's
not going to do anything to help us have
meaningful conversations about this
issue